[Musique]
coluche est mort mort dans un accident
de moto près de grasse il avait 41 ans
nous a fait rire ce soir qu'on pleure
rien ne laissait indifférent coluche ce
soir comme tous les soirs je rappellerai
donc que nous sommes le jeudi 19 juin
1986 et que cela fait quatre cent
cinquante quatre jours de détention
pour marcel carton et marcel fontaine
393 jours de détention pour jean paul
kauffmann et michel seurat 103 jours de
détention pour l'équipe d'antenne de
philippe rochot aurel cornéa jean louis
normandin et georges en scène et 43
jours de détention pour camille sonntag'
les otages français détenus au liban
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir c'est vrai coluche est mort il
s'est tué dans un accident de moto près
de grasse dans le département des
alpes-maritimes un camion lui aurait
coupé la route
coluche est mort sur le coup cette mort
la frappe tous les esprits comme celui
de cet enfant qui a appelé il ya
quelques minutes pour dire c'est pas
juste
nous allons revoir coluche l'artiste
l'homme engagé le clown politique mais
tout d'abord commençons accident est
arrivé
philippe gassot coluche est mort sur une
route de campagne il faisait beau les
amateurs de grosses cylindrées étaient
allés faire un tour avec des copains
balade fut un camion débouche manoeuvre
lui coupe la route
c'est le choc le camion se préparait à
entrer dans une décharge la cabine
tournai n'y avait plus la moindre place
pour passer un mur coluche la vue trop
tard
la moto s'est couchée le comédien a
heurté de la tête l'avant du poids lourd
c'était d'ailleurs est paru il m'a
déboucher dit d'y aller vite
ah oui très vite combien et à quelle
vitesse va pas me dire mais je vous dit
qu'il allait très vite il a eu le temps
de freiner
il n'a pas pris il n'y a pas le moindre
le freinage heures ces coupures sont
arrêtés sont paris s'est arrêté lui
c'est vraiment déplacé la béquille et
l'a touchée par terre voilà ils sont
tous partis à faire c'est malheureux que
sont les jours 10 heures selon d'autres
témoins coluche ne roulait pas à une
vitesse excessive
il connaissait bien cette portion de
route il l'avait emprunté plusieurs fois
ces derniers jours et coluche était un
passionné de moto il aimait son cheval
de fer et il ya plus d'un an sur un
circuit italien il avait battu le record
du monde du kilomètre lancé dans la
catégorie des 750 s'en occupe de série
on le voit ici en train de préparer sa
moto c'était un passionné depuis 20 ans
de la moto écoutez
[Musique]
j'étais dans ce milieu là j'adore ça
habille j'aurais voulu être pilote et
puis ben j'ai jamais fait je crois que
j'ai bien fait coluche de son vrai nom
michel colucci était né le 28 octobre
1944 à paris il était le fils d'un
peintre en bâtiment c'était l'artiste
incontesté du round du rire et de
l'humour décapant
il avait fait ses débuts au café de la
gare un café théâtre avec miou-miou
patrick dewaere et gérard lanvin
notamment l'artiste coluche l'homme à la
salopette à rayures bleues france roche
quand on disait coluche le public criait
ce soir le nom de coluche fait pleurer
oublier sa provocation ces mots lui
triol ce visage lunaire ce cor anglais
sont sans vie déguisés en femmes comme à
la cérémonie de son mariage avec le
luron il avait monté il ya moins d'un
mois l'escalier d'honneur du festival de
cannes car malgré ou à cause de ses 15
ans de succès il raffolait des farces et
des déguisements en salopette éclatante
sur scène ou à la télévision en veston
rose
il était apparu l'an dernier en général
névrosée dans le fou de guerre
désormais chaque matin nous avons son
réveil d'une demi-heure de manière à ce
qu au fur et à mesure vous habituels pu
dormir que deux ou trois heures et oui
le sommeil et avis
l'échec de ce film tourné en italie et
celui de dagobert l'avait poussé à
revenir à la télévision à la radio où il
retrouvera le même succès que pour tchao
pantin couronné par un césar
c'est de la vraie joie joie
ça commence par un joueur on sait
comment ça finit ils étaient contents ce
jour-là coluche l'amuseur d'être reconnu
comme un grand acteur
c'était le rêve exaucé du jeune michel
colucci fils d'un peintre en bâtiment
qui après avoir tâté de douze ou treize
petits métiers avait été un des
fondateurs du café de la gare où il
avait fait entrer une petite vendeuse
qui l'avait baptisé du nom coca c'est
gentil de miu miu
la carrière cinématographique de coluche
fut faite de hauts et de bas de bons et
de mauvais film mais sur scène il avait
toujours triomphé provocateur dérangeant
à la limite dangereuse du trop méconnu
chez mais dépassé les bornes
comme les limites de vitesse en rodéo
automobile en moto ou dans le show
business il allait vite
à 41 ans il avait vécu 16 ans de succès
un divorce une dépression et récolté
beaucoup d'amis qui peuplaient jour et
nuit sa maison ouverte à tous ceux qui
avaient besoin de ne pas être seul lui
aussi aimait la foule celle de son
public
des témoins de ces farces ou ceux pour
qu'ils réinventent une radio ati
conformiste
devinette quel est l'endroit où les
femmes sont le plus prisé en afrique
coolus nous provoquaient pas seulement
sur scène et pour rire il avait poussé
la provocation jusqu'à nous mettre au
défi de faire vivre les restaurants du
coeur les restos du coeur de tendre la
main aux pauvres d'ici et d'afrique
hervé brusini un badge une chanson en
une seule image toutes les vraies audace
de coluche tout oser tout faire contre
le racisme contre la faim vous est brave
et l'administration mobiliser toutes les
énergies pour leur dire à eux aux
nouveaux comme aux anciens pauvres qui
est un voile à une simple porte de toile
un chapiteau c'est ton resto le resto du
coeur l'initiative coluche a démarré à
l'hiver 85 tous les records pulvérisés
plus de deux millions de repas servis et
toujours toujours grâce à l'audace
[Musique]
les politiciens bon on a confiance on
n'a pas confiance ça dépend mais en tout
cas on sait quelque chose c'est que il
ya officiellement 600 mille personnes
qu'on prêt à bouffer en france qu'à tous
les jours et les mecs vous dis ça comme
un chiffre et quand on leur demande
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire pour pour ça
ils disent bas et je sais pas alors nous
on sait on le fait voilà ben oui voilà
voilà qui nous faisait le coup du touche
pas à mon pote
voilà qu'ils osaient se souvenir de son
vrai nom michael et colucci y en a qui
sont beurre parmi vous comme on dit moi
je suis fromage mais d'origine parmesan
quand même présent dans toutes les faits
dans toutes les manifestations il jouer
avec les nations les patries tout matmut
au son du il osé même jouer avec les
couleurs ou disons le pouvoir des
couleurs
comment reconnaître un français da
l'immigré c'est très facile sur vos
images
les français sont habillés en bleu
l'immigré c'est celui qui a les mains en
l'air et qu'on fouille à pour ça les
critiques n'ont pas manqué
l'inacceptable ses blagues racistes
les restos du coeur quel pub rien à
faire coluche rester là la superstar au
coeur brooke gros comme ça ça va allez
salut tout le monde samedi soir encore
il était à paris place de la bastille
pour saluer les potes tous les [ __ ]
la mort de celui qui fait rire est sans
doute plus insupportable sur l'instant
dans les rues de paris dès que nous
avons appris la mort de coluche nous
avons sollicité quelques réactions à
chaque fois ce fut l'incrédulité
emmanuel vanille
pas possible sont pas prêts
je pense pas trop y croire je crois pas
ouais
cependant monsieur qu'est ce que vous
pensez de coluche a connu très mal élevé
c'est le triste match et il est mort il
ya une heure passage ensuite
parce que c'était je crois tout au moins
qui avait un grand coeur
le manche
mena
est ce que vous pensiez les personnages
le moment été bien utilisé ce qu'ils
pensaient
les mines question qui meurent chaque
jour
d'abord de coluche et vous laisse
indifférente
ce week-end hier j'ai pensé à lui
je détiens coluche on le voit plus
souvent à la télé dit maintenant il est
mort c'est dommage c'était
tu es un homme de coeur
je l'aimais
sur la scène le comique coluche ne s'est
jamais privé d'interpeller les
politiques où qu'ils soient et quels
qu'ils soient
il est allé sur leur terrain à la fin de
l'année 80 quelques mois avant
l'élection présidentielle de mai 81 pour
présenter sa candidature
un tour de piste de clown pour secouer
ce qui se prenaient au sérieux
jean-michel mercurol coluche candidat
aux présidentielles c'était en 80 comme
un pied de nez aux hommes politiques
candidature provocatrice se jouant des
conventions il réussit tout de même à
réunir plus de 600 signatures d'élus et
obtenir le soutien de quelques
intellectuels extensible pour amener des
tas de choses j'ai dit que je serai
candidat jusqu'au bout je le serai jusqu
au bout pour emmerder la droite jusqu'à
la gauche et je le ferai
en fait qu lui se contente de
l'inquiétude qu'il a pu susciter dans la
course présidentielle et le trouble fête
se retire dans un éclat de rire
sa philosophie politique je ne suis pas
un nouveau riche mais un ancien pauvre
conduira sais pas a lille il ya quelques
mois parmi les personnalités de gauche
venus l'écouter le président de la
république au cours de la campagne des
législatives le président de la
république monsieur françois mitterrand
réagi à l'elysée avec tristesse savent
annonce de la mort de coluche qu'il
connaissait c'est un déchirement c'était
un amoureux de la vie et ils viennent la
perdre il était la vie même l'expression
de la verve populaire françois léotard
mise la culture la nouvelle est venue
comme une mauvaise histoire mal a
raconté celui qui dérangeait n'est plus
jacques toubon secrétaire général du rpr
il était devenu une institution
georgina dufoix c'était un homme de
parole jacques chirac
j'apprends avec tristesse et émotion le
décès de coluche toute sa carrière
témoigne d'une grande verve comique et
satirique indiscutable il avait su
mettre sa notoriété au service de causes
généreuse et puis harlem désir
avec qui il était samedi soir place de
la bastille aucun mot aucune phrase ne
pourra résumer la tristesse et la
douleur que j'éprouve en apprenant la
mort de michel que je n'arrive pas à
admettre
harlem désir qui dirige assuré sera 6
ajoute coluche avait su redonner espoir
aux paumés obama né aux [ __ ] comme
ils disaient tous les potes sont
aujourd'hui orphelins un des leurs vient
de les quitter et c'est injuste
peut-être coluche sera-t-il moquer de
ces salut posthume et j'ajouterais
seulement une phrase de miu miu
je ne sais pas ce qu'on va faire sans
lui dans quelques instants
guy bedos viendra rendre hommage à son
ami coluche à la télévision demain
service minimum un même programme sur
les trois chaînes publiques des journaux
à 12h45 et 20h un programme minimum en
raison de la grève lancée à l'appel des
syndicats techniciens journalistes pour
protester contre le projet de réforme de
l'audiovisuel engagé par monsieur les
auteurs la riposte syndicale hausse le
ton puisque 2k vie de grève ont été
déposés pour les 25 et 26 juin prochains
jours de retransmission des demi finales
du mondial
l'explication gay non lic le mondial
compromis préavis de grève pour le 25 et
26 d'autres préavis peut-être pour les
jours suivants selon les syndicats c'est
l'absence totale de négociations avec le
gouvernement qui les contrats à durcir
leur mouvement
nous sommes une situation nous n'avons
pas le choix nous sommes agressées on
the des fruits les entreprises détruire
nos emplois
casser les services publics il ne nous
reste pas d'autre moyen pour alerter
l'opinion publique pour dire c'est un
problème de société
un problème grave qui ne peut pas être
et sa beauté dans un des mâts dans un
débat faciles ou trop rapide au sénat à
l'assemblée nationale c'est quelque
chose qui concerne tous les citoyens et
par rapport à ça nous sommes obligés
nous sommes contraints nous sommes
amenés à prendre nos responsabilités
mais la responsabilité principale du
durcissement incombe au gouvernement qui
ne veut pas entendre raison se cette
affaire nous ne prenons jamais été
spectateur en otage il la situation veut
que nous sommes amenés à faire des
grèves qui est un moyen légal et
constitutionnel nous utilisons nos
droits et par rapport à ça je ne vois
pas ce que l'on peut nous reprocher
personnel est calme déterminé mais
absolument décidés à pas se laisser
mener à l'abattoir et livrent les
entreprises et les emplois ce n'est pas
la grève illimitée ce n'est pas la grève
à coup sûr les syndicats se réserve le
droit d'agir ou non entre le 25 et le 29
juin
ces dates ne sont pas un hasard c'est
une menace menaces adressées au
gouvernement suites d avatar de la
cohabitation politique ce matin le
conseiller diplomatique de monsieur
chirac évoquant le conseil européen de
l'efs des claques les positions de la
france se définissait à matignon
sous l'égide du premier ministre cet
après midi mise au point l'elysée
cela regarde au premier chef le
président de la république
manifestement paul amar il y as
divergences d'interprétation oui c'est
la première fois depuis le 16 mars qu'il
ya une divergence public entre les deux
hommes sur la politique extérieure et
sur leur rôle respectif dans un secteur
qui leur tient à coeur
l'europe la lecture rapide de ces deux
déclarations peut même donner le
sentiment qu'ils sont en désaccord total
sentiments sans doute un peu exagéré les
réunions préparatoires sont en effet
relativement bien déroulé et nous le
confirme des deux côtés mais tout de
même on ne peut pas ne pas se poser la
question cette divergence risque-t-elle
de compromettre le sommet européen de
l'aïe à cette question la réponse est
catégorique aussi bien à l'elysée qu'à
matignon
non le président et le premier ministre
n'ont pas l'intention d'exporter même
chez nos plus proches voisins leurs
querelles de famille mais comme ils
n'ont pas l'intention non plus de renier
leurs propres convictions
il leur faudra bien trouver un terrain
d'entente et résoudre le problème avant
même de prendre l'avion pour la est un
problème qui se pose d'une manière très
concrète aussi bien sur la forme que sur
le contenu sur la forme qui sera le chef
de la délégation françois mitterrand
nous dit-on sans hésitation à matignon
mais jacques chirac quand on vient
s'exprimer à la haie et s'exprimer
publiquement
il ne sera pas silencieux comme à tokyo
sur ce point le président au public
semble être d'accord sur le contenu
ensuite la france aura-t-elle sur tous
les dossiers la même attitude
par exemple l'afrique du sud un dossier
très délicat on sait que les deux hommes
n'ont pas tout à fait la même position
mais il semble tout de même improbable
que cela apparaisse à la et l'image de
la france en souffrirait et cela les
deux hommes tiennent à l'éviter s'il ya
un point sur lequel ils sont d'accord
c'est bien celui-là coup de force de la
police contre les trafiquants de drogue
dans le nord à bavay 7 kg 180 d'héroïne
pure ont été saisies aujourd'hui dans
quatre quartiers de paris des opérations
de contrôle comme ici contre l'identité
notamment wallon était organisée par la
brigade des stupéfiants cette opération
policière et douanière interviennent
coïncidence tragique au lendemain de
l'annoncé
la mort de la petite fille de l'écrivain
kavanagh morte à 18 ans d'une overdose
cet après-midi le docteur francis curtet
discuter avec ceux qui sont souvent en
première ligne face aux trafiquants des
collégiens des lycéens
c'était devant une caméra d'antenne de
reportage agnès poirier
bonsoir une jeune fille est morte elle
avait 18 ans elle s'appelait marie elle
est mort d'une overdose
il faut que cela se sache je suis un
petit bonhomme sa marque sur la gaine la
sortie de son histoire les petites
filles n'ont commis que ce soit quelque
chose fougères
chez moi on n'aborde pas ce sujet parce
qu'ils ne se sentent pas concernés par
la drogue pour moi pour eux suivront
leur fille ils fuient pas concernés vont
même s'ils savent que j'ai des copains
les amis qui se droguent ou qui ont déjà
goûté mais s'ils savent que je suis apte
à le côtoyer
ils ne sentent pas concernés pour eux
fini parfaitement heureuse que c'est pas
de problème
j'en ai pas tout à fait mais ils se
rendent pas compte que ça peut m'arriver
aussi à moi d'y goûter
je passe je crois que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui veulent enfin tenter un
des aventures et je crois que justement
la drogue est quelque chose qu'il est
qui leur paraissent très intéressant
même même risqué sa vie je crois que
c'est leur paraît quand même quelque
chose de plus le passionne je crois que
c'est un moyen de montrer qu'on est là
de crier un peu son malaise montrer que
ça va pas maintenant quand on a 16 ans
la mort c'est lui moi même
c'est vraiment loin c'est la dernière
des choses c'est ce qui est plus loin
c'est la chose même si on y pense c'est
bon on va vite en moto on va vite en
voiture on se dit oui bon on peut se
planter mais la mort on la voit vraiment
loin mais entre parenthèses vraiment
très très loin je crois on se demande
comment on pourrait faire une bonne
prévention et c'est là qu'on voit quatre
éléments considérables à faire
moi je continue à penser malgré tout
qu'il faudrait peut-être le faire avant
tout avec les parents peut-être parce
que ce genre de discussion s'il pouvait
avoir lieu au sein d'une famille on
gagnerait la torche où elles ont 16 ans
leur année de seconde se termine sans
problème dans un lycée privé parisien
les jeunes filles comme les autres mais
comme les autres fragile une procédure
d'arbitrage est en cours entre paris et
washington pour régler les différends
franco néo zélandais du rainbow warrior
cette procédure est organisée suivie par
le secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur
perez des coignard
à noter également qu'un premier
communiqué commun franco néo zélandais a
été publié on approche peut-être du
dénommé paul lefèvre
depuis le début de la sphère la france
et la nouvelle-zélande avec intérêt à
régler rapidement la situation mais elle
devait également veiller à ne pas faire
perdre la face à l'autre
la france voulait évidemment récupérer
ces deux officiers la nouvelle-zélande
avait besoin que la france lève ses
réserves entre guillemets aux demandes
économique de la nouvelle zélande auprès
de la cee
on vient d'apprendre que le gouvernement
français a fait le premier pas la
nouvelle zélande peut donc maintenant
faire le second dôme à des marges
d'autant plus possible qu'un médiateur
le secrétaire général de l'onu est vite
maintenant le face à face aux
conséquences parfois conflictuelles et
que surtout monsieur lang et possède
toujours dans sa poche
le joker si vous me permettez
l'expression qui lui permettrait de
régler le problème
il s'agit d'une disposition de la loi
des océans days sur l'immigration qui
permet d'expulser les étrangers
condamnés avant la fin de leur peine
monsieur lang ne s'opposent plus
semble-t-il à ce que les thuringe
terminent leur peine dans un territoire
français on pourrait donc se concevoir
que pour ménager la susceptibilité néo
zélandaise il s'agit officiellement
d'une disparition momentanée dans la des
départements français d'outre-mer
ensuite les officiers seraient rendus
discrètement à la liberté donc encore un
peu de patience les rapports franco
iranien s'améliore concrètement il y à
90% de chances que la france achète de
nouveaux du pétrole à l'iran ce qu'a
précisé l'un des quatre émissaires
officieux iranien qui se trouve
actuellement à paris
tout va bien aussi entre paris et pékin
et le secrétaire général du pc chinois
hu yaobang qui achevait sa visite en
france aujourd'hui était manifestement
très content aux côtés de monsieur
mitterrand un chinois à paris mais pas
n'importe lequel du rheu milliards
monsieur hu yaobang et numéro deux à
pékin
à ce titre il a eu droit pendant son
séjour tapis rouge et aux visites
privilégiées
monsieur une visite qui se terminait
aujourd'hui par une conférence de presse
solennelle à l'elysée
conjointement avec le président françois
mitterrand
monsieur hu yaobang est sans doute un
peu méridionale il parle chinois mais il
appuie son discours par des gestes de
conviction
la france et la chine sont d'accord sur
les principes pas toujours sûr et
solutions on a aussi bien sûr par les
marchés et coopération achat d'une
centrale nucléaire desservant canton et
hong kong achats d'airbus deux centraux
téléphoniques
le cimenteries les échanges franco
chinois ont progressé de 40%
c'est à dire quatre années avec
notamment un contrat qui porte sur la
fourniture de 300 locomotives monsieur
wang a d'ailleurs pris le tgv pendant
son périple est à l'étape il a déclaré
que son pays doit entrer dans le monde
moderne à grande vitesse bilan du voyage
c'est évident on sait parfaitement
compris bien répondre à ces questions
coupe du monde de football la surprise
ce fut hier soir la défaite du danemark
les danois n'en sont pas encore revenus
ils ont d'abord ouvert le score un but
sur penalty et puis ensuite ils ont
encaissé cinq buts cinq bus des
espagnols alors pensez donc la fête à
madrid fait à madrid racontée par notre
envoyé spécial philippe lefait
11h30 juste dans les quartiers pauvres
de madrid
on prend son mal en patience en
attendant l'échéance tout le monde sait
que l'espagne a ses chances
les héros de felipe de ses copains sont
évidemment au mexique
à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi de 8
à 88 ans pour aux riches on a ici qu'une
préoccupation la pelote à la balle c'est
le seul plaisir ici petite maison petite
retraite
peu de moyens de distraction alors la
passion a depuis longtemps débordé la
barrière des sexes partout l'opium du
peuple et un futur dieu espagnol emilio
bouteraa gheniou le buteur de l'équipe
d'espagne devenu meilleur buteur du
mondial il fait son métier il va marquer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
1-1 le ballon fait de madrid un désert
pas moyen ce soir à de se promener
encore et d'échapper à la fière les
fenêtres sont ouvertes
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
chez les intellectuels du centre on a
rangé la planche à dessin et la machine
a écrit la machine à crampons espagnol
et l inexorable
[Applaudissements]
à 81 comment est ce qu'on fait quand on
n'aime pas bon il ya deux jours d'autres
choses à faire on peut aller voir un
match de rugby par exemple
il y avait fière à 4 1 il ya folie douce
et la victoire est déjà dans la rue à
5,1 on se voit en demi finale non en
finale et non champions du monde même
pilar applaudi derrière elle pourtant un
nom de chômage et un banc public pour
passer la nuit météo de demain vendredi
laurent bouvier et oui il faut savoir
que demain vendredi sera le jour le plus
long de l'année alors le jour le plus
long de l'année ça ne veut pas forcément
dire le jour le plus beau jamais regardé
la photo satellite malheureusement les
nuages reviennent déjà la voilà qui
arrive des nuages qui étaient là
aujourd'hui sur l'atlantique tu as une
dépression qui est elle aussi sur
l'atlantique ces nuages vont se décaler
dans la nuit pour recouvrir de main
toutes les régions de l'ouest du pays
donc des nuages de nouveau quelques
risques d'orages regardez la carte du
temps prévu avec toujours quelques
risques d'orages le matin sur le sud est
c'est normal ça fait deux trois jours
qu'ils sont là il devrait s'en aller
mais nous ne sommes pas très vite et
puis cette nouvelle perturbation qui
abordera en fin de nuit
toutes les cotes allant de la bretagne à
l'aquitaine qui variera dans la journée
disons le quart ouest du pays donnant un
temps parfois nuageux voire couvert avec
quelques averses sur le nord est puis
quelques orages parfois violents
sur les pyrénées et sur le limousin sur
le reste du pays c'est à dire sur le
nord-est temps encore agréable est
encore assez ensoleillé côté
températures elles sont en hausse
températures tout à fait de saison de 21
à 30 degrés sur la moitié nord 30 degrés
à paris et 30 degrés à strasbourg et
mulhouse
et puis de 27 jusqu'à 30° également sur
la moitié devait les températures tout à
fait agréable sachez que sur le reste de
l'europe il fera à 26° à la fois à
genève et à jérusalem notre agenda pour
terminer le voilà qui arrive demain sera
le vendredi 20 juin le jour le plus long
de l'année le soleil se lèvera à 5h48 se
couchera 21h56 une petite minute de
soleil en plus c'est la dernière à
partir de maintenant ça va commencer à
diminuer et nous nous fêterons silvert
quelques instants après avoir appris là
la mort de coluche mort dans un accident
de moto à grasse dans les
alpes-maritimes
on a eu cette phrase de miu miu je ne
sais pas très bien ce qu'on va faire
sans lui
alors on a voulu s'élever miu miu à la
fin de ce journal
on n'a pas voulu des grandes phrases on
a simplement voulu un témoignage dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur coluche
je suis un petit peu hébété d'être là
parce qu'il ya une heure bref c'est
exactement le genre de chose que je
déteste de venir parler d'un ami la
télévision et en même temps j'aime pas
non plus aller aux enterrements et puis
j'y vais parce que parce que six
personnes mais elle fait bon bref ce que
je peux dire de coluche sans faire le
phrasé sans faire du violon parce que
c'est pas le genre de la famille je
pense que je peux pas parler de lui au
passé puisque c'est vraiment trop c'est
quelqu'un qui a amené toute évidence
c'est quelqu'un qui a la personne qui
l'a menée depuis vingt ans sept ans mais
je le connais depuis 17 ans qui a amené
un son en somme
en musique on dirait un son complètement
personnel qu'on les aime quand même pas
et c'est absolument un caddie câble sur
la qualité sur la sur la chique la cité
mais public l'adoré 1 il vous est poussé
il vous est un peu emmerdé dans sa
manière de faire il vous a obligé à
changer votre manière de travailler de
nous faire rire moi j'ai connu tout
petit si je peux dire maps et papa alors
se charger un peu une réaction je
déteste les motos je déteste les motos
et lui les aimer oui mais moi je les
déteste plus que jamais à part ça oui je
les ai connus
je les ai connus dans un film j'avais le
rôle principal et les élucubrations
n'est pas et avec berry on n'a pas été
long remarqué son talent sa verve ce ton
tellement particulier c'est évident
qu'est ce qu'il faut garder dans sa tête
ou dans sa poche ou ou alors règles de
connu ce qu'il y avait
il avait plusieurs mois je me suis
trouvé quelques fois en tête à tête avec
lui il enlevait son nez rouge et il y
avait une vraie personne qui était là
avec la sensibilité des roues fait rire
et pour faire rire comme comme il le
faisait
et comme il le fait encore j'entendais
c'est complètement différent parce que
quand un ami connu humeur ans l'entente
en le voit dans tous les journaux on
l'entend à la radio c'était ans et c'est
quelque chose de j'ai déjà
malheureusement connu ça déjà avec
quelqu'un de proche qui est dieu qui
était récemment et c'est presque
insupportable alors bon mais j'ai pas de
choses très très très cohérente à dire
parce que je suis vraiment sur le coup
et c'est très dommage pour pour le
spectacle france est très dommage même
si guy ne va accepter de venir là demain
20h dans soir merci
[Musique]
e